Sara's with us in California hi Sara
welcome the Dave Ramsey show hi hi Dave
thanks so much for taking the call sure
um I'm calling because me and my
boyfriend are hoping and planning to get
married next year and we just started
Financial Peace University to get our
finances in order and kick our marriage
off on the right side next year one of
my babies number two I only have about
six thousand dollars in credit card debt
and no car payment not including my home
and my boyfriend on the other hand has
about seventy five thousand dollars in
debt thirty thousand of which is a
student loan but fifteen thousand
dollars of which he owes to people like
friends and family members things like
that and I'm not sure how we work that
into the debt snowball since it's not
really an institution and these people
probably aren't going to be too thrilled
with $25 a month $50 a month
do we if they're not really hurting for
the money and hoping for it right now
should we focus on the institution's
first and then pay them off when we get
extra money Dean so series you look at
this you know we're hypothetically
thinking and talking about this because
until you guys say we do you don't right
okay because you don't have it together
I mean you you guys aren't combining
anything right now it's individually so
we're we're talking about your boyfriend
situation until he becomes your fiancee
and husband but looking at this you know
not share his you don't share his debt
but don't sharing the debt that's my
point so bad on the debt and I've taken
on a little bit more in the household
then so he can focus on paying okay he
needs to run that snowball you run them
and then when you're married you run a
combined one that's what Christmas yeah
and so this 15,000 and how much of it is
owed to his family he owes me like
seventy five hundred and eight thousand
is owed to his friends okay well upon
the ring going on your finger that debt
would be forgiven then because you can
owe yourself money that's weird right
yeah so that got rid of half of it okay
getting married gets right a half of it
and so because it'd be kind of silly for
you to pay yourself back I mean that's
one pocket into the other so that's
right anyway so here's the thing that's
bothering me more than anything we can
answer your question tactically and
technically and that is is that it goes
in the debt snowball right in order and
I wouldn't pay them $25 a month I would
just build up the money in a separate
account as if you were paying them
payments but pay yourself payments until
you got that thousand dollars than
cinema thousand bucks and pay them off
whoever it is if it's a thousand dollar
bet balance I get that you don't want a
$25.00 the relative or the mother or
whatever it is to death the thing that I
do want you to be comfortable with
that's been addressed and I really want
him to be comfortable that's been
addressed is that this borrowing is a
symptom of habit patterns in his life
that need to be gone before you are
married right he actually was unemployed
for most our relationship and just
started under a very good job so now
I've been unemployed then they were
about $15,000 from friends and family
certainly not my girlfriend yep and
that's why we're focused on this now and
we're getting all of everything in order
I'm okay I'm not mad at him I'm just
saying the debt is not the problem it's
the symptom including when Dave Ramsey
was stupid with that okay it was a
symptom of other stuff going on in my
life and I want to make sure old Uncle
Dave wants to make sure that Sarah has
is real sure that whatever was wrong has
been corrected because what was wrong
caused this mess in his life and I don't
want you to have to do this over six
times in the next three decades of your
marriage because he never has addressed
the heart issue that's around this so as
long as he's done that I'm okay and I
would just work at that snowball
separately until you're married and then
once you're married you're 7,500 is
forgiven and the rest of it goes in the
debt snowball you build up if let's say
you owe mom two grand is painting the
money into savings account those two
grand and send her a check for two grand
as if you were paying payments but you
just pay them to yourself and still work
them straight through it's rigged it's
you just it's all debt it's all got to
go away and the fastest best way for it
to go away smallest to largest that's
clear-rite